[Music]
i can get help with whatever depending
on the price how do i break out of
transactional based relationships
i can get help depending on the price
and that's fascinating right like like i
can help other people
i can and that therefore i'm buying
their love
right so if i
were to pay for this person's rent for a
month that shows how loving i am or if i
buy this trinket for someone it becomes
transactional love but of course love
isn't
transactional it's transcendent
and
yet we're constantly doing this there
are ways specifically like mary you can
turn a relationship into
a transaction in fact that's what our
last book was about love people use
things right and instead of the opposite
which what we're doing is we're using
people and one way to do that is to
treat relationships
transactionally and now there's a part
of it where
that is required right if i am going
into a restaurant and i want to buy some
food there is a transaction that takes
place but it doesn't mean that i have to
be unloving to the person there in front
of me i can be loving to them
regardless of whether or not there's a
transaction that's about to occur so a
transaction can happen
and love can happen
the problem is we conflate the two yeah
and i i i
i noticed that over the last 20 years
with my students
man
the work world is all about networking
now what can this person what can this
relationship get for me yeah and what
can that relationship do for me so that
i can get that relationship so i get
that job
and we have
roid every human connection and i think
that's a dangerous dangerous place to be
um i have to be able to love and serve
people because it's the right thing to
do going back to your analogy i can
lovingly and with dignity and respect
tell somebody dude you totally blew my
meal at this restaurant right like this
is what i ordered it's not even cooked
like i'm paying you good like but i can
do that with dignity and i can do that
with respect and kindness and i can't
not be like hey right because that's
about my ego and that's about but i
think it's circling back to
um this was hard i forgive
for me
i'd say that's me taking a break out of
my back i'm not i'm gonna choose to not
carry this thing your stuff yeah i'm not
going to carry it for you right i'm
going to choose to not let you circulate
around my thoughts day after day not
after night that's a choice i am going
to choose to make
i am going to forgive for me i'm going
to serve
you need things and i've found that i've
got a particular um
thing that can meet a need i've got
money that i can donate i've got an
ability to speak that i can do for free
i i'll do some things but i ultimately
have to know that service is gonna be
again it's going to keep me whole and
keep me well so i'm going to continue to
serve because it's right
if i make my identity about trying to
fill everybody else's needs then that is
nothing that's not service that is
that's uh i'm using you as a as a
uh
like i use you as a tool to make me feel
better about myself yeah and that
becomes a different type of transaction
and so one of the things that we all
become a vampire right
yeah parasite i'm gonna take your soul
so it makes me feel better right yeah
and going all the way back to our like
first thing i'm going to take your
autonomy by telling you you will always
be the worst thing you ever did you will
always be the worst thing that ever
happened to you you're always going to
be an ex-survivor of something you can
never grow out of this and so i've got
to come save you you're a victim and i
can say forever that's all you will ever
be so you need an entity you need a this
or that to come help you out of your
thing because all you will ever be is a
fill in the blank survivor and i'm
stealing that from you to prop up my
thing instead of coming and saying
you were abused and that shouldn't have
happened or looking at you and saying
your dad shifts
your dad should have loved you i'm sorry
yeah and that service doesn't happen
yeah that service doesn't have an
expectation
and right and i think that's the
difference a transaction
has an expectation right i gave you ten
dollars you gave me my burrito
that's the transaction right and that
opens up space if i want i can be loving
that person i can be mean i could be
spiteful i can be arrogant
and or
i can
serve someone without any expectation of
getting something back and that's how
you remove the transaction from the
relationship there's no ledger in the
relationship i'm giving to you if you
give to me wonderful but there's no
expectation here i don't need that in
order to be complete i don't need for
our relationship to be quote improved
right i can serve other people without
needing to get anything back for it yeah
this makes me uh it's just like just
conjuring all of these netflix things
that i've watched where people take
advantage of other people
and uh it all has to do with money and
it all has to do with the transactions
and they do exactly what you were
talking about john they're like
um you are the worst thing you've ever
done um i'm going to pull you out of
that but in order to do that i need you
to find out how to get find a way to
give me 40 000
i mean there is like there is some crazy
stories out there like the um there's
one called the tinder spindler it's like
a documentary yeah i've heard about that
yeah and it's just like that you could
tell
that this man essentially was you know
finding his own self-worth through the
abuse of these relationships that he was
that he was starting but you know
whenever like
i look at from the outside looking in
it's easy to be like
why are you such an idiot like why in
the world would you i wouldn't do that
you know
um because you know i i would you know i
tell myself like if all of a sudden my
relationship with someone started to
become all about the transactions
specifically monetary transactions like
red flags are going to go off in my head
but man when you uh
when you're dealing with that emotion of
love or lust or whatever it is
infatuation
um
you know those those alarm systems can
be
shut down a little bit yeah there are
there are
way fewer red flags than we like to
think right way few i uh you know i was
born raised i lived most of my life in
texas and just the man if something goes
down dude i've got my and i'm gonna and
i used to think no you won't
you know what i mean i've been to the
scenes after it goes down you won't you
know what i mean and but you don't know
you're like
shoot man would that girl start talking
like that you know what i would say
nothing you say absolutely
will smith would slap me on stage right
yeah yeah you wouldn't have done
anything either
absolutely nothing yeah you want to know
yeah dude like
that may have been the most
one of the most beautiful pictures of
poise i've ever seen yeah
never yes yes totally agree you want to
know what a soul at peace looks like
chris rock yeah after getting slapped
yeah that's
yeah
dude i remember like that was the yeah i
don't i know you're all probably talked
about this before sure but a little bit
yeah we don't have to talk about what
will's working through but i just
remember seeing that thinking
that's how you do that yeah like you
stand there and smile it's all right
we'll go to break and like there's no
bigger flex to me there right i mean i
don't know there's something about i i
don't i
my ego my worth my whatever comes next
isn't dependent on
yeah like all the cameras and it's not
dependent on that did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free